hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
sonic mania Wow where to start with this
one well let's make something clear from
the outset sonic mania is a love letter
to the 16-bit era to the 1990s to
blogging on cats is when they wouldn't
work if any of those three points
resonate with you then sonic mania is
the perfect retro title for your
collection here's six reason why if you
couldn't tell by my opening gambit
nostalgia is the most powerful force at
work during sonic mania by incorporating
elements of the first three Sonic games
plus callback human sonic CD sonic
Knuckles and sonic heroes amongst others
this game is the quintessential sonic
title it plays just as you remember on
the Sega Genesis or Mega Drive but with
a sexy full HD image with many of the
less attractive areas being removed
iterated upon or modernized
to great effects it's essentially both a
festive and a real sequel to Sonic 3
so if you call it a blast from the past
or return to bomb your right either way
of course nostalgia can only get you so
far before the mechanics at work must
take center stage and once again
sonic mania is a retro masterpiece
although this is the typical
left-to-right side-scrolling platformer
that Sonics made his name on there's
more than what it seems at face value
the uses of minigames special States
variety and variation give us a rest
from the car gameplay loop to great
effect defeating Eggman in a minigame
mid levels are stumbling across a
special stage wormhole in the shape of a
giant golden ring of course make
exploring each zone a real pleasure the
level design in general is balanced
between original layout and new design
elements each though is huge when
compared to the original trilogy with
every level now bigger wider longer
faster than ever before at no point does
it feel too much either due to the
checkpoints and the unique hook each
zone promotes the expanding world now
stimulates replayability as we all find
the best routes through the madness or
where those hidden secrets may be
[Music]
the new zones are well thought out and
are keeping with the 95 and if anything
more new content or mechanics could have
further added to the whole spectacle of
Sonic mania the balance between 2d and
3d visuals and gameplay keeps Sonic
mania interesting and varied from the
Green Hill Zone right through to your
final battle the art style has remained
as true to Sonic's route as possible
with visual and very deliberate
pixelation on each right it may not be
pushing the hardware to the limit but
the sprite scaling and super smooth 60
frames a second are a joy to behold the
way bosses leak from the background to
the foreground or vice versa gives the
2d elements depth and vibrancy the
[Music]
musics are yet another area of
brilliance
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the original star has been lovingly
modernized without losing any of the
character we know and love I even found
myself waiting to drown to see if their
nineties return and of course HD
[Music]
what a retro game without a good old
boss fight
well sonic mania is enriched with
numerous subversive in each zone the
files are extremely varied and although
a few takes a little figuring out they
are all short enough to be spun with
only one set of bosses with a real
critical key curve by the way am I wrong
calling Sonic's enemy dr. Robotnik I
just don't feel right saying egg month
it seems a bit rude can you let me know
what you call it is it dr. Robotnik was
the Eggman the price is the final point
of greatness for this full-fledged sonic
outing costing 16 quid here in the UK
and $20.00 in the u.s. with all the
territories falling into line with those
costing if you only have five minutes to
gain or a few hours Sonic mania can fit
Bobcat
all in all sonic mania is the strongest
for most of the 1990s done any modern
game I have ever played the attention to
detail the sheer size scope and variety
tomainia is a delight to behold the
nostalgia will hit you like a ton of
bricks for anyone to enjoy Sonic as a
child it's so overwhelmingly positive
even though most of the game's levels
have been completely redesigned and even
if this is your first foray into 16-bit
platforming then what a place to start
this is the pinnacle Sonic mania has had
such an impact on me that I found my old
Mega Drive and plumb to wade through my
library of classic Sega Genesis titles
Thank You sonic mania I imagine from
PlayStation granade it's been an
absolute pleasure now I'm off to find
more chaos several critics dope
[Music]
you